all right I got no jokes I got no witty
quips I just want to talk about this so
let's go Sherlock series two in America
we say season to the Brits say Series
two so hey we hold to that or I hold I
don't know who we is all right so I've
already reviewed series 1 of Sherlock
you know what I feel about the entire
thing it's awesome so now I watch series
2 and I will say this plainly after the
first episode aired I turn to my friend
and I was like that was good TV I love
the first episode that is how you start
a season off or series first of all you
have I read learn all right Rachel
McAdams plays Irene Adler in the movies
and what I've realized this show does is
not only take the characters that you
know from the movies and make them a
zillion times better but it also makes
the Robert Downey jr. movies irrelevant
because this is the definitive Sherlock
experience comparing the BBC series
Irene Adler to Rachel McAdams Irene
Adler is like comparing the Christian
Bale Batman to the George Clooney Batman
you think back you're like yeah that
other one just isn't it's not memorable
but this character in the show yeah
memorable to say the least she's awesome
she's sexy she's smart she is
competition for Sherlock one of the
coolest moments of she comes out and
Sherlock can't size her up he looks at
Watson just immediately mentally sizes
him up you see cliff notes all over
Watson's face and clothes obviously he
still has it it goes back over to her
just question marks that's what I knew I
was like this is gonna be a good episode
I didn't know it was going to be a great
episode
my least favorite episode of the entire
series is the second episode the hounds
of Baskerville episode and I understand
why they had the episode in it because
hounds of the Baskervilles like an
iconic thing you know you can't have the
Sherlock show and not have the
Baskerville episode that being said I
felt like it was the weakest link you
come off of the Irene Adler episode the
scandal in Belgravia really strong
opener really great characters a good
character episode for Sherlock Holmes
then you go to this which is just pretty
much an episode they have their mystery
they have to go to it they have to solve
it but you don't feel the gravity of the
situation for Sherlock Holmes and Watson
like if they never went to that case and
took on that case I don't feel like
their lives to be any different you
don't feel Jim Moriarty's Clause than
anything you just feel like it's an
episode
however for moving on to the third
episode that's the Jim Moriarty episode
just like series 1 the third episode is
Jim Moriarty versus Sherlock Holmes now
we get it again I'm going to show a
picture of Moriarty
kind of have to at this point a series
to the fun of series one is not really
knowing who Moriarty is now you've met
him at the end of series one now he's
taking on Moriarty so here's the picture
this guy right here the maniac Moriarty
and that was my gripe in series 1 if you
remember I saw Jim Moriarty I was like I
don't like how they're doing I felt like
when I first met Jim Moriarty at the end
of series 1 first of all you have like
two minutes to get to know him but
second of all I felt like he talked like
Pollux Troy from faceoff room I guess
it's hard to really know where they're
gonna take a character in about two
minutes of screen time Jim Moriarty in
series 2 I get where they were going
with it I liked how they did and I did
use crazies out of his mind I mean you
know that if things are happy you're
like this guy is crazy then by the end
of the episode you're like this guy is
[ __ ] insane and you love it like he's
insane in that really cool Kefka from
final fantasy 6 kind of way he's insane
in eccentric but he has the will and
determination to really pull it off he's
not just going after Sherlock Holmes
he's going after the Sherlock Holmes
legacy he is going to crush this guy
when I walk away from entertainment of
some kind after I see a villain and I am
quoting the guy for like a week I know
I've met a good villain
Moriarty is one of those people I like
him the more I think about him my only
gripe is that I don't feel it shows him
enough I always want to see more of
Moriarty and again it's the bummer I
think back to the Jared Harris Moriarty
I love the dude I felt he was a perfect
Moriarty for the Moriarty that were
going for in the movie however is he is
interesting as the Moriarty and the BBC
Sherlock he's not kind of funny how
perspective does that you know like you
love the Jack Nicholson Joker and then
Heath Ledger's Joker came out you're
like yeah he's just better a strong
opener a great villain a strong ending I
don't know how they could have made this
any better I'm getting these on blu-ray
that is a fact it's happening I wanted
to watch this immediately again right
when it was over I just wanna be like
sweet but in disc one let's do this
again really this is the definitive
Sherlock experience I can't stress that
enough I love the fact that it made it
take place in modern times didn't make
it feel like a gimmick I mean really
when Sir Arthur Conan Doyle penned the
Sherlock stories they were in modern
times for him now they've just adapted
it for modern times for us I guess
there's a new Sherlock series coming out
in America or Lucy Liu plays Watson I
have no interest in seeing it whatsoever
I have found the holy grail of Sherlock
I will go ahead and stick with those
thank you I really don't rate shows but
the BBC
Sherlock is awesome tacular it's got to
make it official you know you just have
to I think any written text that's
written with the intent to be spoken
should be written by the writers of
BBC's Sherlock this has some of the best
writing characters and dialogue that you
will find in entertainment period so
have you seen the BBC Sherlock what did
you think of it how did you like season
2 in comparison to season 1 what's your
favorite episode so many questions so
little time if you say it sucks I don't
even know what moon of what planet you
exist on but I'm still curious comment
below let me know and as always if you
liked what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more